hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google in a previous
episode I talked about list view
animations where we would remove of you
and then animate both the swipe of the
item out of the list view as well as the
collapse around where the item used to
be animating all the other views into
place so that was all good you can run
that kind of animation on the property
animation system that goes all the way
back to 30 the demo I'm going to show
today looks remarkably similar to that
but there's an important twist to it so
first let's see the demo if you want to
go back and watch the previous show and
certain context for that that's fine
okay you're back here we go let's run
the current demo and this should look
remarkably similar to what we saw before
so we swipe an item out if we swipe it a
little bit it animates back into place
if we swipe it further it animates out
and then it animates the gap to be
closed so here's the twist if we run
this on gingerbread which is on my Nexus
S here you can see the same animation so
this is a question I get a lot with my
animation demos is G all this property
animation stuff is really cool how would
I do it on older releases hopefully that
issue is going away over time but if you
are concerned about gingerbread releases
still for our application then maybe we
can see how you could get this kind of
technique even on that older release so
let's take a look at the code I'm not
going to go over all the elements of the
code the background drawing in the
shadow and everything that was in the
previous talk just go ahead and check
out that other dead bites as well as the
google i/o animation talk that that demo
came from instead i just want to focus
on the aspect where we're able to run
both the new property style animations
as well as the older animations so in
our touch listener we're listening for
these swipe events and we're doing
essentially the same thing we're
listening for the down event and we're
tracking where that down event occurs
and then in the move event we figure out
where the new exposition is to figure
out how far to move this thing and at
this point you might be thinking yeah
but but we're actually we're using
translation X like we're using a
property that
doesn't actually exist on gingerbread so
how does that work ah that's the key
okay so before we could get the
translation x value and we could set the
translation x value and these are view
properties that came in at 30 on
gingerbread those properties don't exist
on view so it's a little bit difficult
to work with them there so instead what
we do is call this set swipe position so
I refactor the code so that we can sort
of do the correct thing on either
release gingerbread or non gingerbread
post gingerbread so in that method sets
y position you can see how this works so
if runtime is post gingerbread this is
what we did before we simply set the
translation x value we basically pop
this item that we were swiping over to
the appropriate place and then we set
the alpha value to be more or less
translucent based on how far away it was
from the original position or how close
to the edge of the screen if you're on
gingerbread that property doesn't those
properties don't exist we don't have
alpha we don't have translation X so
what can we do we can work with the old
style animations this is this was the
animation the system that existed prior
to 30 but we can use that for actually
setting these properties and kind of
faking the way that you look so it
essentially looks the same it's not
quite the same because there is no alpha
property but it is more translucent so
it's effectively visually the same thing
so we can set a translate animation on
the item we can set an alpha animation
on the item and we can create an
animation set to bundle both of these up
we add both of these animations to the
animation set we set fill after and fill
in able to true which means they're
going to hold their value even when the
animation is over and then we're going
to start the animation so basically we
set up animations on these things and
we're going to effectively set the alpha
and the translation property of this
item by running these animations to a
particular value and we're going to run
notice they're actually running the
translation animation basically from the
current value to the current value which
means we're going to just slam it in
there where it's going to start and end
to the same value and even though the
animation is ended we've set fill
enabled to true and fill after the true
which means that they're going to stay
at that
value so that's the trick to actually
not animating the swype but actually
setting the swype to be at the right
position under the user's finger okay so
that's setting this way but then we have
the other behavior of actually animating
the thing after it's removed so we come
in here and say okay when the user lifts
up if they were swiping this item then
we want to figure out how far to move
and then we want to animate the swipe so
we call this other method down here
again we've refactored this into a
separate method where we either do the
gingerbread thing or the post
gingerbread thing post gingerbread this
looks similar to it did before if you
saw that other video we animate we use
view property animator we're animating
alpha or animating translation X here we
use a listener so actually this
animation will work all the way back to
31 there's no dependency on the jelly
bean api of with end action in view
property animator anymore instead we
just set a listener and when the
animation ends then we do the
appropriate thing we restore values we
animate the to close the gap all that
stuff if we're running in Gingerbread to
animate the swype this looks remarkably
similar to what we saw before where we
were setting the swipe position we're
doing is animating swipe position now so
we're starting from the current X and
the current alpha value from wherever
that item ended up and we're animating
either off the screen or back into place
again we're using an animation set we're
no longer setting fill enable because we
don't want to hold a value when we're
done instead we just going to animate
off or animate back and when the
animation ends then we are either
restore values to where they were if we
were animating back or we animate the
other views and for this one we want to
animate the gap closed so using the same
technique that we used in the previous
demo in the previous dev bites video we
figure out where all the views are and
we associate those view positions with
the item ID so we're using a stable ID
array adapter here again and we store
these in a hash map and then we remove
the item from the adapter that forces a
notified data set change that will force
a layout but before that layout is
displayed on the screen our on pre draw
listener on the view tree observer
in and we can now track the positions of
all the views in the current version of
the list view and figure out what item
ids those are associated with compare
them to the other item ids and animate
the changes again all of this is the
same as before the only trick here is
how to actually make it work in
gingerbread so we remove the pre draw
listener we figure out where things need
to go and then we run the animation
which is right here move view runs the
animation to actually shift these things
on the screen again we have a
gingerbread and non gingerbread version
of this thing the non gingerbread should
look remarkably similar to what it did
before except in this case we're
actually using object animators sort of
interchangeable with view property
animator view property animator is a
little bit more of a streamlined API I
happen to use object animators in this
case in the gingerbread version again
we're using a translate animation pre 30
api's and we're saying okay I want this
view to move from the current start and
end X&Y positions and those were
calculated according to where the item
contents were before and after the
layout change on the list view and we
set the duration and we start the
animation and that's it really fairly
straightforward the only trick was that
the old approach was using properties
that didn't exist on view prior to 30 so
we can't use that so we use the old
animations instead to fake the system
out and make it look the same and then
the animation same thing we were using
animation api's based on properties
didn't exist prior to 30 so instead
we'll use the old animations that didn't
use properties but give the same visual
effects to what we're doing everything
else is the same logic track the item
ids before and after where the views
associated with those item ids were and
then simply animate the changes and
that's it so go ahead and check out the
animation talk called a moving
experience at Google i/o to get a little
bit more glimpse into how the demo
actually works and the reasons behind it
and check out the other devbytes videos
to see the overall structure of the code
and some of the other elements
didn't talk about today and check out
the code for this demo thanks